okay wir würfeln weiter die 71 23 4 567
übrigens bei 10.000 gleichkommt 100
zufällig bei burger king bestellen oder
vielleicht irgendwo anderen eltern
herzlich willkommen bei einem video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
mir gerade eigentlich auch ziemlich gut
außer dass ich ziemlich großen hunger
habe aber darauf habe ich ja auch
gewartet leute heute gibt es das na ja
gut so interessant ist es jetzt auch
nicht aber es wird bestimmt witzig und
zwar kennt ja vielleicht meine videos
von letzter woche 100% zufällig auf ebay
amazon wish und so weiter bestellen
da gibt es natürlich auch noch weitere
teile von ich habe mir nur gedacht
alex du isst so gerne lecker essen
deswegen machst du das heute einfach mal
mit pizza wollte wir bestellen heute 100
prozent zufällig bei einem pizza
lieferservice jetzt fragt ihr euch
sicherlich alex jedoch erst mal zum
friseur bevor du pizza bestellt das
stimmt allerdings habe ich den termin
als nächste woche spaß also fragt euch
jetzt bestimmt alex wie willst du denn
zufällig bestellen und zwar ganz einfach
wir gehen auf lieferando einfach weil es
auf lieferant und die meisten pizzerien
hier in köln gibt soweit ich weiß dann
werde ich die kategorie pizza auswählen
und da werden wir dann wahrscheinlich
114 vorgeschlagen die halt wirklich zu
dieser adresse wo ich wohne liefern und
diese pizzerien haben ja immer
unterschiedlich viele produkte mancher
mehr produkte manchmal weniger produkte
aber diese produkte sind alle in
kategorien unterteilt das sind dann
meistens so zwischen zehn und 25
kategorien angenommen das sind jetzt 20
kategorien dann werde ich mit dem
zufallsgenerator gegen eine zahl
zwischen 1 und 20 würfeln praktisch es
kommt dann die achter kategorie jetzt
einfach mal beispielsweise raus und dann
werden wir aus der achten kategorie die
jetzt eventuell dann keine ahnung
getränke sind ebenfalls wieder einen
zahl würfeln und so kommen dann halt
bestellungen zustanden ich bin gespannt
was ihr am ende bekommen werden das
ganze wird natürlich auch bestellt und
das war für mich auch ist ja klar wenn
ihr das prinzip jetzt noch nicht
verstanden habt dann versteht jetzt
gleich sicherlich und ich würde sagen
wir fangen jetzt sofort denn ich habe
echt eine menge so leute wir befinden
uns jetzt hier auf lieferando.de das
ganze ist übrigens kein placement ich
finde es gibt auch bessere seite als
lieferando aber da gibt es halt einfach
am meisten pizzerien ja und wir lassen
uns jetzt hier einfach mal an
was ist denn für die adresse hier
leckeres zu liefern gibt die wählen dann
hier an der seite einfach mal
italienische pizza aus und hier werden
wir jetzt 40 verschiedene pizzerien
angezeigt ich habe mir übrigens gedacht
ich möchte meine fünf produkte haben
also ich will jetzt auch nicht für 100
euro bestellen weil das kann ich alles
essen fünf produkte klingt logisch mit
pizza mit nachtisch mit getränk und so
weiter hört sich voll um gesundheit
irgendwie so dass jetzt 40 pizzerien
gibt habe ich jetzt einfach eingestellt
hier wird mir jetzt irgendeine zahl
gewürfelt zwischen 41 und ich würde
sagen das machen wir jetzt einfach mal
okay wir haben hier die elf bekommen und
jetzt muss ich einfach die elfte
pizzeria nehmen also 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 pizza ball juli hat glaube ich
schon mal pizza bestellt ich allerdings
sony elfmeter rausgeholt
ganz klar danke thailändisch
italienische pizza und amerikanische
pizza lieferzeit ca 30 minuten
lieferservice ist gratis
das hört sich doch schon mal ganz gut an
so wir gehen mal drauf alter wir haben
jetzt 12 3 also hier hat man wirklich
einige kategorien ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen es soll ja heute eher und pizza
gehen deswegen würde ich sagen nehmen
wir alle kategorien des burger und
nehmen dann hier diese kategorien raus
und dann halt erst wieder ab bis er ihr
zweiter mit erzählung weil ich meine ich
habe gar keinen bock auf asiatisch das
heißt wir mehr 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 bis zu burger und dann 13 14 15
verschiedene kategorien die anderen
darunter dieses asiatische und kid box
und so können durchweg denken so leute
jetzt kann ich hier einfach wieder
weiter durchkämpfen und ich würde sagen
wir fangen an das nächste ziel jetzt mit
der ersten kategorie und es ist die zahl
7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 panini pizzabrötchen
kann man immer gebrauchen wir haben ja
ungefähr zehn verschiedene produkte und
wir dürfen einfach mal die zwei ich
hätte zwar lieber die mit käse gehabt
aber mit hausgemachten juli hört sich
gut an
in den warenkorb gut das haben wir schon
mal da jetzt wirklich für die nächste
kategorie und das ist einfach nur schön
also wir fangen an hier oben
12345 käse pizza
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich fahre
nicht so krass ich bin mal gespannt
vielleicht können die denn na gut wir
gehen einfach mal drauf okay und wir
würfeln weiter die 71 23 4 567 pizza
vegetarier käse wand mit blattspinat
frische paprika frischen champignons und
knoblauch das hat sich für mich jetzt
nicht sooo lecker aber was willste
machen
vielleicht können wir einmal drauf gehen
geht gar nicht ach so vielleicht ihre
gratis zutaten ich nehme die ohne
knoblauch ich bin doch nicht blöd halter
ich will keinen knoblauch frau knoblauch
auf eine pizza das schmeckt nicht okay
wir ballern hier in den warenkorb für
zehn euro 70 schnäppchen ist es jetzt
nicht und wir dürfen weiter wir kriegen
schon wieder die vierte hamburg schon
bestellt das weiß ich jetzt nicht gelten
die 9 ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 mai pasta
hier gibt es allerdings so viel pasta
gerichte deswegen haben wir jetzt die
zwei hinbekommen und die zwei spacig
passt damit curry sahne sauce hört sich
läppern in den warenkorb warte man
erstmal muss ich noch ich möchte wir
bald an dass in den warenkorb 1950 okay
also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
getränke wären nicht schlecht und ich
glaube des bisher oder 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12
okay die nächsten fallen raus das haben
wir am anfang gesagt 13 14 15
alkoholfreie getränk wird hier sind wir
bei den getränken und getränke gibt es
wahrscheinlich viele jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt was er sagt und das ist die 8
okay leute die nummer 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
coca cola light man muss ja auch immer
an die figur denken das ist ganz wichtig
war doch einfach mal die coca cola light
in den warenkorb und zu guter letzt ein
produkt noch so jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt wir hoffen hier die 13
ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 bisher
movie aufnahme wurde unterbrochen wir
haben hier die 1 ok mousse au chocolat
hört sich gut an und haben jetzt 25 euro
im warenkorb was eigentlich voll fett
geht ich hatte jetzt schon 50 gerechnet
also wenn ihr schaut einmal die paninis
also diese pizzabrötchen pizza
vegetarier basic pasta coca cola light
und du musst du chocolat
wir bestellen so leute ich habe jetzt
gerade bestellt die bestellung ist
angekommen bei denen ich habe auch schon
die bestätigung bekommen und ich bin
gespannt mal gucken ob die wirklich nach
halben stunde da sind und dann schauen
wir mal wie es schmeckt ja ich freue
mich ist gleich so ich habe es gerade
ist wirklich auf diese kämen
wir müssen glaube ich noch eine halbe
stunde warten und ich hab hunger also
wir sehen uns gleich wieder ja
eigentlich war das wird unendlich
aufzunehmen um eine sache ja so wie sich
das bei uns gehört spielt julia hatte
den abwasch ja damit ich gleich auch
logischerweise gut frische tanne hat es
von pfizer ist also wir sind ausgleich
28 nacht klingelt ist da glaube ich dir
zurück
das lustige ist eigentlich immer bei uns
in der wohnung egal wenn irgendwer
fremdes an unserer tür vorbei geht
vielleicht nach personen die tür gerade
auf ist weil von uns hier raus geld man
sieht immer sofort diesen kalender so
das erste ist endlich da ich habe mega
hunger und wir wünschen jetzt mal kurz
wieder rüber auf die andere käme so
leute alter ich hatte gerade die ganzen
sachen auf dem stuhl ständen ist so
schön angenehm warm es ging echt schnell
also eine halbe stunde wie es im
internet stand schaut dort schöne grüße
gehen raus das habt ihr richtig gut
gemacht ich will einfach mal hier ein
bisschen mit dem handy mit und zwar
haben wir hier einmal die nudeln die
sind extrem heiß dann haben wir hier
einmal den all you need is sieht ganz
gut aus vor allem schön kühl das feiere
ich richtig dann haben wir hier die
mousse au chocolat und da bin ich auch
mal gespannt ich denke mal das ist jetzt
nicht frisch gemacht sondern einfach so
ein fertigprodukt das hier sind die
pizzen und brötchen
ja das sind die filter brötchen alter
sogar echt viele montieren wir
wahrscheinlich die pizza bestellt habe
zeige ich euch allerdings jetzt gleich
vier fangen jetzt an zu essen so und ich
würde sagen ich fange einfach mal mit
dem pizzabrötchen an
ja da kann man jetzt eigentlich nicht so
viel erwarten ich weiß natürlich auch
wie die schmecken
ich finde juni tipp ist echt richtig
geil wenn er öfter mal in spanien oder
gibts auch in jedem rationen war juli
also die pizza brüche sind dann
sicherlich lecker sind nur irgendwie ein
bisschen weich und ich habe auf jeden
fall schon besser vergessen die waren so
ein bisschen zu ja wie soll ich sagen ja
ein bisschen zu hart für mich fast dann
würde ich sagen wir machen einfach mal
mit den mädels und auch zu heißen machen
einfach mal sofort mit der fritz
arbeiter und die pizza sieht sie ist
nicht geschnitten
[Musik]
an wen
das finde ich ist immer ein richtiges no
go wenn man so eine pizza bestellt als
wenn man die selber zu hause schneiden
will die richter auf jeden fall echt gut
normalerweise würde ich nie auf die idee
kommen so eine pizza zu bestellen ist ja
klar also leute so sieht die pfütze aus
ja eigentlich echt lecker spinat
wir werden sehen ob das schmeckt also
die vegetarische pizza mix corp ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich finde den spinat
schmeckt man gar nicht halte ich bin auf
jeden fall positiv über geschmäcker und
vor allem schmeckt ist gesund ja
natürlich ist es jetzt nicht so gesund
aber es ist auch nicht so ungesund
wieder angriffe sei die cola light ist
auch ganz gut gekühlt das ist ja das
wichtigste sonst nichts das habe ich
hier die nudeln riecht eigentlich echt
gut die nut und sehen so aus es sieht
nur so aus als wäre die soße da ein
bisschen runter gelaufen also oben drauf
ist kaum soße übrigens bei 10.000
gleichkommt 100% zufällig bei burger
king bestellen oder vielleicht irgendwo
anders also leute gebt durch mir recht
heißt muss man sagen also die haben sich
gut waren aber sie schmecken
okay vielleicht es ist mir ein bisschen
zu wenig gewürzt aber sonst sind die
auch echt gut also schmecken lecker
natürlich erst sich die sachen so gut es
geht gleich noch auf
deswegen denke nicht dass die pizza
gelegen oder so nur ich möchte ja
natürlich erst mal für euch probieren
damit das video nicht zu lange und zu
guter letzt haben wir hier noch die muße
schokolade schokolade mag ich sehr gerne
habe ich früher auch immer gegessen so
sieht es aus ich wünsche euch einen
guten appetit beziehungsweise hier mir
einfach in die kommentare wer hunger hat
und die ist wirklich richtig lecker also
alles in einem ist es richtig gut es
schmeckt gut es war schnell da es war
bin ich nicht zu teuer
gut die pizza hut zehn euro kostet aber
das ist finde ich für so eine
vegetarische pizza okay also pizza ball
schöne grüße heraus sehr gut gemacht
gerne wieder und ich würde sagen dass
war es eigentlich mit diesem video 100%
zufällig pizza bestellen ich hoffe
natürlich dass natürlich gefallen lassen
nach oben darf mir noch ein paar wir
sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen wieder
ach so etwas noch ganz wichtig ist
schreibt einfach weitere vorschläge was
ich vielleicht noch machen soll und
weitere artikel alles irgendwelche
sachen die man kaufen kann irgendwelche
produkte egal ob es jetzt essen ist oder
ob es andere sachen sind die man
vielleicht auf amazon oder sonst
bekommen kann in die kommentare
damit ich auch noch weitere parks drehen
kann weil ich das recht unterhaltsam
witzig finde und ja wir sehen uns ich
hoffe dass wir dadurch gefallen habe ich
schon gesagt gar 36 instagram ab